If your site uses a basic username and password based login system, you can specify login
credentials for Burp Scanner to use when scanning the site. Specifying a valid username and password
enables Burp Scanner to login to the site and audit content that only authenticated users can
usually see. Please note that adding a username and password works well for sites that use simple
login forms with only two input fields. However, if your site uses a more complex login mechanism,
such as SSO, then you should use a recorded login sequence instead of username and password based
login credentials. Burp Scanner may be unable to login otherwise. Also note that you cannot use
both credential types on a single site in Burp Suite Enterprise Edition. To begin, we can navigate to
the sites page, select Create New Site. We scroll down to the scan settings and select the Application
Logins tab. By default, the Add Usernames and Passwords radio button will be selected. We can
then click Add Login Credentials, give this a label, enter our username and then our password. We can now click Save.
If you want to edit an existing site with Application Login Details, we can navigate to the sites page,
select the site in question, select Details tab, and then Edit. You can scroll down to scan settings and select
the Application Logins tab. Again, by default, the Add Usernames and Passwords will be selected and we can add our
login credentials. Give it a label, our username and password. We can now click Save.
If we want the scan to crawl with multiple user accounts that might have different permissions or views,
we can select the plus button and add a second set of login credentials. Multiple sets are supported.
If for whatever reason we need to delete a set of credentials, we can just select the Trash icon.
Thank you.